There definitely is a lot
of Paris life and culture in Arcane.
I mean, I don't think
it's a coincidence that, uh,
a lot...
of Piltover looks like Paris.
Things are designed to be functional,
but also... to be a piece of art.
I think that's something
very much in the French, kind of, spirit.
Yeah, so this venue...
is actually where we had
Worlds a few years ago.
It was cool
because it was really close to our studio,
so, we sent some people from Fortiche.
It was something really special to
finally be able to share that with them.
I think they were fans
of the story and of the characters,
but you kind of also have to experience
the buzz in the world around the game.
[IN FRENCH]
We saw straight away that this was...
a world-wide game
and the chance to do
something really, really good.
[IN ENGLISH] For us,
Arcane was a big opportunity
to show to viewers that we are not
only good for making trailers
and music videos.
[IN FRENCH] It really starts with a
joyful,
passionate intention to make a film,
or a TV show,
and not just marketing.
[IN ENGLISH] If I'm confident about that?
Uh...
I don't know.
I hope...
people are going to be surprised.
I think everybody on the project is...
out to prove something
with what we're doing
and I firmly believe that...
you need to find someone
who's kind of willing to...
bleed for this thing
they're trying to make.
I don't think, otherwise, you're going...
to be bold, otherwise,
you're not going to have anything...
where you'll risk something.
And you have to risk something in order
to make something that makes an impact.
A very, very competitive scene
here, at Fortiche,
about what they call...
is it babyfoot right?
-Babyfoot?
-WOMAN: Babyfoot, yes.
CHRISTIAN: The suspense is killing me!
WOMAN: It's killing us, too.
Ah, there's the worthy goal!
CHRISTIAN:
Basically, the idea for this trip is to...
get into a room with the directors,
the animators, the editors,
and just brainstorm a bit, together, like,
"What would be
the coolest version of this scene
or this episode?"
So, you're just worried
about it being too complex?
AMANDA: My goals this whole time is,
I want to solve the story beats
with the team in Paris.
It's just going to be great to be, like,
"Hey guys, here's all our awesome ideas,"
and then they tell us
whether they can produce it or not
or steer us more
into something achievable.
It's not done till it's done.
It's like the block of marble,
chiseling away.
And then occasionally,
you knock off an arm
and have to start over.
If we ever proceed with this scene
without taking in...
that input from the directors here,
it's worse,
because they're so talented,
they always find this creative spin.
Pascal has this amazing eye...
...for character designs,
the models, the stylization.
[IN FRENCH] I don't know
if we could put in some camera shake?
[IN ENGLISH] I'm just the man of shadows.
Jerome, he's...
the invisible wizard at Fortiche.
Today, I want to be at the lab
to experiment with new things
for the future, with Riot.
CHRISTIAN: I think,
when you think about the final look,
that painterly look
that's integrated into 3D,
the super subtle, nuanced camera work,
where everything feels
like it's hand-held
and really human and real,
a lot of that is Jerome.
-De-aging with me, please.
-Okay.
I want some de-aging.
INTERVIEWER: Who is Arnaud?
Who is Arnaud? Uh...
Ah. Who is Arnaud?
He tells us, "You know
what I want is a... Psh!
what I want is a... [MIMICS EXPLOSION]
you know what?"
-Who is Arnaud?
-Who is he?
So, this is the Arnaud model.
So, um, the hair is pretty detailed.
Um...
And then, he doesn't have any pants.
And...
ANIMATOR: They wanted to incorporate
the three directors in the show.
Happy Progress Day!
When Arnaud has, like, a crazy idea,
best thing you can do
is shut up and let him do his thing,
because it tends to be
when the cool shit happens.
I loved that they added them
as kids in there.
It was not something
we thought of in the room...
...but it just added
this level of emotion between them.
Honestly, it's like,
"Oh, I feel like these characters
could be in love now."
This sequence is in every way,
technically, artistically...
It's, I don't know how to say that,
the masterpiece of the whole season.
CHRISTIAN: This particular image to me
is, like, the combination...
You know, Hextech is art and science,
and I think that's exactly
what I feel the Fortiche depiction is.
I feel the science,
I feel the power, I feel the energy,
but I also feel the beauty.
ARNAUD [IN FRENCH]:
What I like about Fortiche is
that we breathe life
into the original vision
and everyone kind of adds their stone...
-...to the building.
-...to the building, as we say.
So...
[IN ENGLISH] So, basically,
this board is all the steps
that happen at Fortiche.
After we receive the script,
we go to the design phase,
which basically is doing design
for characters, props and backgrounds.
[IN FRENCH] In this case,
this boat here was made by Viktor
and actually putting this boat
in the scene is a way
of showing that, even as a child,
Viktor was a genius.
[IN ENGLISH]
Then, everything goes to storyboard.
In the storyboard department,
we take the scripts
and we work with the directors.
We try to build something
that is not there yet in the script.
But there's also editing,
who are working at the same time
in order to really find
the good timings for the boards.
As an editor,
my job is to assemble
those storyboards together
into what we all an animatic.
And then, while that's happening,
you're recording
the dialogue with the talent.
I love a good conundrum.
Hammer forging is such a delicate art.
Shimmer is rampant in the Undercity,
attacks at the Hexgates
and in the Academy square.
Yeah, but I-I said I already called it.
You can't do... I called dibs!
We get voices from the actors
and then we cut them with sound effects
and temp music
in order to see the movie
and see how it works.
We're watching
full-on storyboard animatics
with the voice actors in there.
VI: Vander learns none of this.
MYLO: No worries there.
Powder took care of the evidence.
I tried, okay?
So, we were able to watch the whole season
from start to finish before we animated
the rest of the episodes.
You did this?
I mean, honestly, on every aspect,
we were afraid
of this moment in the episode,
because it's not always easy
to, like, get these really raw,
emotional performances
from really young actors.
And so, Mia Jenness,
who we cast for Powder...
I remember going into the VO session
and being, like, "All right,
today we're going to make
an 11-, 12-year-old girl cry.
Um… let's see how that goes."
MAN: And rolling on this.
She left me...
She is NOT my sister anymore.
I remember all of us
in the booth just, like,
being shocked by how good she is
and just...
being in tears at the end of the... takes.
MAN: And I think we got it.
Yay!
I got the job when I was 10
and I'm almost 16,
so it's been a while.
Why did you leave me?!
Because you're a jinx!
No... No... No, Vi, please...
To get into that place of vulnerability...
was hard for me.
Vi! Vi, come back! Please, come back!
Please, Violet, I need you! Please...
I have a little brother
who is my best friend in the entire world.
We get upset when we don't see each other
for, like, more than three days.
I can't imagine a world
where he isn't in it.
-Where's the...?
-Oh, you're back!
Thinking about what that would be like
if something had happened that made it
so that we couldn't bounce back,
next thing I knew,
it was all just coming to the surface.
I only wanted to help...
I only wanted to help.
I only wanted to help!
I only wanted to-
I told you to stay away.
When it comes to siblings,
they're your blood.
And when you don't have family,
what do you have?
You've got a good heart.
Don't ever lose it.
No matter how the world tries
to break you.
[IN FRENCH]
When we heard the voices, we were, like,
"Ah, maybe we could have
something really...
special, something much more subtle
and much deeper in terms of acting."
I always knew you'd come back.
What's going on?
When we heard the voices, we went,
"Ah, we could lean
towards Scorsese instead."
All the main characters
were really scary to cast.
Because-
I mean, you're not just making a new character.
It was, like,
"Oh yeah, there's... whatever, six years of...
a hundred gazillion, million people
who have very specific expectations
and opinions
about who these characters are.
So don't **** it up."
Wow, super boring.
Jinx took us the longest
of all the characters.
I think we looked for the Jinx actress
for roughly three years.
ALEX: She's so beloved
and her voice is so specific.
For a while, we were, like,
"Can we find someone who can do this?"
CHRISTIAN: The hard thing was
that we had to find someone who could do both...
the intimate and quiet moments
that are these
really vulnerable acting moments.
But at the same time,
we also needed an actress
who can also do the really loud moments
that Jinx is really known for.
And you typically can find
one or the other.
We were at a point where it was,
"We've been looking so long."
We kind of went through
all of the LA catalogue of talent.
"Let's just pick one and just go."
And it was just, like, "No, we can't."
And, at some point, through the help
of some casting folks,
we found Ella.
Hi.
And, I mean,
it was like the Pearly Gates just opened.
Well,
look who it is.
The Boy Savior!
I felt this really
deep connection with her,
because of empathy and compassion,
on compassionate grounds.
Yes, she's...
a terrible person,
she's done all these terrible things.
But is she a terrible person?
I don't know.
I started to realize, like...
who's she's become,
this Jinx that she's become, is just a...
deeply rooted,
very difficult trauma response
that she's developed
because she's gone through things
no one should have to go through.
No... No, it was a mistake...
[IN FRENCH] It's true,
the acting, I think, in Arcane, is
much more advanced
than in most animated shows,
because our desire was more to try...
and really copy the actors,
and sometimes, the casting even influenced
the design of the characters
and their attitudes.
[IN ENGLISH]
In parallel with the storyboard, we're going to do
background
and character-props fabrication.
At the beginning,
we work at the same time as animation,
so it's sometimes difficult to know
exactly the position of the characters.
You can see it's 2D, in black and white.
I'm not painting it
because there is Silco there.
[IN FRENCH] What I like is the
evolution of the characters in the story.
And she has a really big evolution.
I think that's why
she's my favorite character.
I like the fact
that she's a little bit crazy.
But at the same time, she's...
not that crazy,
not that wicked.
[IN ENGLISH] So, we've got designs,
and from there,
we just build it in 3D.
Yeah.
It's very simple...
...to explain.
So here, we made the Atlas Gauntlet
and... the most difficult part was,
there are a lot of tiny parts
that work together.
So, before it gets
to the rigging department,
we have to be sure it works first,
like, all the tiny pieces you see here.
It was engineered precisely
to work like that.
So, it's part of the fun,
but it's part of the headache, too.
It's actually really fun
to create all those intricate pieces,
like the leg and feet of Viktor,
all those weird, metallic parts
blending with the body.
This was the design for the hands.
Then, I modelled something like this.
And then, I gave it
to the texture department
and they painted it so it looks like that.
MATTHIEU: All the process is built
around the idea of bringing the design
to the final image.
And that's great,
because the design
is just brought back in 3D
and it's actually
what the designer thought of.
[IN FRENCH] Here, what I'm showing you
is a rig, a character rig.
It's really joints, fictitious bones,
that we put in place.
So, it's pivot points that we can turn.
We have such a strong team of animators
that they'll find,
I don't know, three or four ideas
to add life to the character.
[IN ENGLISH]
And then, we go to the layout stage
and they start to do the staging
and the camera movement.
[IN FRENCH]
We try to translate the storyboard
into 3D...
and to get across the emotions
just with a camera,
with the camera movements,
or the focal length we choose...
to find nice framing...
and to also find
the rhythm of the animation.
[IN ENGLISH] And then it goes to
animation.
[IN FRENCH] And then perhaps Vander...
He's going to go.
He leaves and then…
He's actually fallen.
You don't need to have a huge distance,
but just feel...
[IN ENGLISH] If you go in a dictionary,
"animation" is giving life to something.
Being animated is just feeling
the passion of something as well.
And us, we are like the puppet masters,
the puppeteers.
No motion capture.
-INTERVIEWER: No motion capture?
-No.
Please, let people know that.
-Why not?
-Well...
Motion capture...
is used when you want
to have some realistic animation...
and only that.
Look out!
CAITLYN: Ah!
MARTIAL: Keyframe animation, it pushes you
to understand what happens in the body,
how everything works together
to have, like, this feeling of natural
and believable animation.
And also,
it's about the style of the show.
It's semi-realistic,
but it's not fully realistic.
We tried to keep
something really hand-crafted.
Animating is, like,
acting out the characters.
It's about performance.
When I saw the style of Arcane,
it was something, like,
"I want to try this kind of animation,
because it's really different from the...
cartoony style I used to be in."
And after working so long in the industry,
I wanted to challenge myself.
To be honest,
Ekko is the kind of character
I would have loved to see
when I was a kid.
Ekko?
One of the first dialogues he has with Vi,
I went with something
completely different from the board
and...
Bart was, like, "Oh,
I hadn't thought about it in this way,
but it's interesting."
And it was the same with Christian.
I tried something
like he was a little bit pissed
and walking slower
and just making this face
and giving a bit of attitude.
Not like a snake,
but, like, this kind of movement to say,
"Yeah, I'm the one controlling the stuff."
BART: So in a shot like that,
the animator,
when he was assigned the shot,
he'd shoot himself
in order to get some references
and that's what gives us
the realistic look
and the live-action feel.
We do work a lot with references.
We go in the reference room.
We shoot ourselves, we try to...
to pretend and be the character
and being the right emotion.
Why aren't you playing with the others?
The video references are really
something that helps you
capture something natural.
Sometimes, you've got a shot to do
and you've got an idea in your head,
and you can probably just go
straight into the computer
and do your stuff, and it would work.
But if you go into the ref room
and you start recording yourself,
you may end up having
some little accident that you do
that can be really interesting,
like, "That's pretty cool,
let's dig into that."
MYLO: Remind me
why we bother with this dump?
AMARA: How can I say no
to such an auspicious offer?
Do you feel like you're inhabiting
those different characters in a way?
Well, you have to.
When you see one second of an episode,
an animator spent a day on it.
So, if you work on an expression,
on a feeling
on a shot that lasts for one second,
you're going to spend a day
having that feeling in your mind,
like, trying to reproduce it.
It's not rare to have... you go around
the animation department,
and you can see people going, like...
Or just this face
where you're just acting what...
That's the common thing in animation, really.
I really wanted to be
part of this sequence particularly.
There are a lot of crazy sequences,
but this one was the one for me.
And when I heard that I was working on it,
I was, like...
It was like a dream.
And I was really happy,
because I had the slow-motion moment
and I had the opportunity
to work with my son
to make the movement of young Ekko.
He's nine years old, almost ten.
We came here to shoot the scene where Ekko
is running slowly, in slow motion.
It was so cool to share that with him.
It was, like, a moment, father-and-son,
and I hope he will remember it
all his life.
MAN: So only experimenting for now
with paintings.
Uh, it's about to be tested.
For the glitches,
we draw them directly on the computer...
...and for this one, we're searching
for another kind of process.
More realistic.
MAN 2: 2D effects
are very specific at Fortiche,
because, you know,
it's a Fortiche trademark,
doing 2D effects on 3D animation.
They're like traditional animators,
doing effects frame by frame.
[IN FRENCH] So, here we have...
the power that Jayce creates
with his hammer.
[IN ENGLISH] I'm drawing frame by frame
and layer by layer.
But sometimes,
it's very difficult
to follow the camera movements,
which are very interesting.
This kind of shot is
really difficult to do,
because the camera
is a little bit hard to follow.
I think I worked
something like three weeks on it.
[IN FRENCH] For ten years, we've made
the 2D effects for Riot's teasers.
On the teaser...
presentation for Jinx,
which was "Get Jinxed",
we found the Fortiche style.
[IN ENGLISH] I have this feeling
when I'm watching something in progress
and we get to the animation phase,
and I'm looking at the animation, like,
"How will you make this better?
How is this scene going
to feel more immersive?
How are they possibly going
to level this up?"
When everything is done, animation,
backgrounds, simulation, 2D effects,
we render it and we composite it.
We've come to the end of the process
and we literally just take all
of what the other departments have created
and we put it together.
Because the background is painted,
there is actually no light
used for the characters.
We have to adapt the characters
to the background.
So when we see, like,
a red light on Sevika,
and it changes to the green light
when she goes further, actually,
technically, nothing is there.
We have to create everything
from what we see in the background.
So yeah, we go from here...
to here.
Compositing at Fortiche is one of their
signature crafts, and it's just...
a straight mystery box for me.
How do they paint the light?
I cannot tell you.
It's not that I'm holding back anything,
but I...
Some of the process,
I don't even understand.
I don't know if I can show you.
INTERVIEWER: The secret sauce.
Yes, it's kind of secret.
The way to light it, it's different.
It's...
a special Fortiche way.
But it's so simple,
when you know the trick,
you say, "Ah, ****."
"So simple."
It's not a magical trick,
it's just artists and people
who are doing beautiful things.
The real magic is in there.
Everywhere!
THOMAS: Because of their handcrafted-ness
and the painter-y look,
it gives this... timeless look
that I think...
even when the technology evolves,
that this will still feel... lasting.
In the same way I can go back
and watch the Disney animations
like Bambi or...
Cinderella, and... it's timeless.
It doesn't age,
because... it's handcrafted.
PASCAL: Nothing is round in the show.
If you have a glass,
if you see this glass,
it's not round,
because a drawing is not perfect.
ARNAUD: If you see the eyes,
the pupil is not round.
PASCAL: Except the gemstone.
This is the only moment
where there is a sphere, a perfect sphere.
[IN FRENCH] So,
the idea is kind of to have each frame
exceed the quality that you can produce
with classic 2D animation.
And 3D lets us do that.
And it's also to make sure every frame,
every time you pause it, it's...
a bit of concept art,
a beautiful illustration.
There's just storytelling happening
at every phase and every level.
MAN: Alex, Alex on the other side of the
ocean, good morning.
Good morning.
So, Ray, I think that was
a great first read.
Can the second violins play that
a little bit softer?
AMANDA: I've never worked on a show
before where...
the musicians are
such an integral part of everything.
CHRISTIAN: This is the Music team.
So, they wrote all the songs.
They've been spending, what, three,
four years on the music for this show, like...
Every TV show, sometimes you get
three or four weeks for an episode
to do music.
I would say that Arcane is all the muscles
that we've grown as a company
in the music-making craft combined.
I really believe that...
what we are doing with music
in Arcane, season one...
has never been done in entertainment.
Period.